moi je veux pas gâcher la fête et je me
suis
[Applaudissements]
dit je suis en partie d'accord avec lui
quand en fait il dit que la france est
un pays quand même bien sensibilisés aux
gestes barrières bien sensibilisés à la
vaccination même s'il ya quelques
quelques personnes non vaccinées encore
6 millions il ya quand même des messages
clés qui sont rentrés dans la population
qui est qui sont autant d'armes pour
nous tous pour faire face à cette
épidémie de colleville face au nouveau
pic épidémique est là où je le rejoins
c'est que c'est vrai que ça sert à rien
de de basculer dans un misérabilisme
terrible qui va saper le moral à tout le
monde le mag noël chez un autre côté
d'un autre côté je dirais aussi que on
peut pas se permettre d'être trop trop
trop trop rassurant vis-à-vis de cette
épidémie qui nous a déjà montré qu' il
fallait faire preuve d'humilité par
contre il en parle un tout petit peu à
la fin patrick peloux avec qui
j'échangeais avec qui on est on est
globalement en phase ils oublient un
truc fondamental c'est que ce que
l'exécutif ne dit pas très bien parce
qu'ils essayent d'éviter le sujet ce
sont olivier ferrand et où le président
macron il faut que les français
comprennent que l'état de la santé en
france et est inquiétant et c'est pour
ça que je suis là ce soir mais oui et
tout à fait cyril la vaccination les
gestes barrière l'aération mais enfin il
le dit un peu mais j'ai le sentiment
qu'il n'a pas osé il ya quand même des
gens qui ont besoin d'oxygène il ya deux
jours dans mon hôpital 60 % des lits de
soins intensifs c'était des patients
qu'aux vide donc c'est quand même des
gens qu'il faut soigner et il l'a dit
aussi il ya tous les autres passions
qu'il faut soigner des malades qu'on
doit opérer les gens condé d'autres
problèmes des problèmes cardiaques des
prêts neurologiques est-ce que ce que
les français doivent comprendre et je
suis désolé parce que c'est pas de leur
faute mais c'est pas de la mienne non
plus l'hôpital a été abandonnée dans ce
pays pendant 20 30 ans je le vois là une
succession politique on pourra disserter
là dessus mais peu importe le constat on
est tous pareils c'est comme ça c'est un
fait l'exécutif on a quand même pris
conscience parce que ils ont organisé le
ségur de la santé au mois de juillet et
c'était c'était bien comme démarche le
problème c'est que dans lé sud du ségur
de la santé par liam les structures
syndicales et les collectifs comme le
mien politiques sont en danger on s'est
rendu compte tout de suite que sa lettre
la catastrophe pourquoi parce que en
fait le secteur de la santé ça a été des
améliorations mais centrée sur l'hôpital
et la santé en france c'est aussi les
cliniques c'est aussi la ville et à
l'hôpital ça n'est pas que les
professions qui ont été concernés c'est
des professions côté oublier le
médico-social et c est le problème cyril
c'est que donc dix-huit mois après le
ségur de la santé aujourd'hui si je suis
là ce soir c'est parce que les français
doivent comprendre que partout en france
il ya des services d'urgence qui ferment
donc qui ferment on ferme la porte voilà
on peut plus y aller il ya des équipes
de ce mur nous sont fermées donc le smur
vous savez c'est un médecin dans une
voiture avec un infirmier l'ancien et on
va se courir une femme qui menace
d'accoucher à domicile ou alors un
enfant qui fait une crise d'asthme ou
alors un monsieur qui va faire une
douleur dans la poitrine sur la
suspecter un infarctus ça ça ferme alors
pas partout mais dans beaucoup
d'endroits le système de santé dont on a
profité jusqu'à maintenant je pense
qu'il a vécu là il est au bord de la
rupture toute son organisation l'hôpital
on l'entend parce que on ferme des lits
il ya des médecins partout qui disent
que c'est plus possible les urgences on
en a déjà parlé la ville en ville il ya
des gros soucis si et des gros soucis en
médecine de ville et bien forcément ça
se répercute sur l'hôpital en fait faut
comprendre que ce système de santé là il
a 70 ans tel qu'il est actuellement et
quand on regarde un peu la chronologie
de son histoire finalement jusque dans
les années 80 c'était pas trop la
catastrophe et puis peu à peu peu à peu
ça s'est effritée et ce qu'il faut
comprendre c'est que c'est un petit peu
comme si on disait une usine de nike
produisez trois fois plus de chaussures
nike mais nous on va enlever la moitié
des machines en fait on dit à l'hôpital
en france travailler mieux en
travaillant
avec oui mais voilà par ben est en fait
la fête soyez soyez meilleur avec moins
de moyens et là alors c'est une approche
comptable un petit peu de l'hôpital une
approche on va dire commercial presque
on demande à l'hôpital de produire son
camp fait soyez des gens c'est pas comme
ça que ça se passe à nouveau ça coûte de
l'argent et si on essaye de de trop de
trop à appliquer à l'hôpital une vision
marchande c'est la catastrophe et c'est
la catastrophe alors en termes de moyens
des hôpitaux qui s'abîme mais c'est
aussi une catastrophe humaine parce que
vous devez comprendre que par exemple
moi je suis médecin anesthésiste
réanimateur j'ai 45 ans moi j'adore mon
job j'ai pas de souci pour le faire oui
depuis le cowitz un peu plus compliqué
on est un peu fatigué tout ça mais si
vous interrogez des soignants en fait
ils aiment leur métier et aujourd'hui
ils arrêtent ou démissionne parce qu'en
fait les conditions de l'organisation de
leur métier n'est plus possible et est
en fait quand ils rentrent chez eux le
soir ils sont pas certains d'avoir
assuré la sécurité des soins la soif est
l'objectif des soignants c'est toujours
de travailler en sécurité alors nous on
a un seul truc à dire c'est vrai qu'il
eut le ségur mais précis le patron le
présent macron doit quand même rouvrir
le dossier santé y a pas le choix parce
que les soignants qui sont encore en
place ceux qui sont là il y en a pas
assez d'abord il y en a pas assez mais
ceux qui sont là il faut les chouchouter
et je dis pas ça parce que c'est la
période de noël mais il faut faire en
sorte qu'il ne s'en aille pas alors et
ça il faut tout faire pour ça